the jurgen experience when did all
this come to light when did people start
understanding
the the negative consequences of
plastics
and your food um
well they came to understand it first in
animals
um because that's the way science works
you know first you do animal studies and
then you try to replicate them in yumas
right
and so um in around 2000
they did some experiments where they fed
a rat food contaminated with phthalates
and then they looked to see how the
offspring
developed right and what they saw was
that the males
were born different
than the females and different from
unexposed males
do you want me to tell you how different
yes please
so this will really interest you i think
what um
what happened is so let's go back okay
so
before the phthalates before you know
early in pregnancy
the genitals are just a single ridge
same in males and females
undifferentiated
okay and then at a certain time and in
mice in rats it's 15 to 18 days of
gestation
the testicles start making testosterone
and then that gives the signal
to produce the male typical genitals
so if they don't have the testosterone
there will be ovaries and if there is
testosterone they'll be
testicles and so on and so forth right
and that
migration requires testosterone at
exactly the right time
and the right amount it's very
delicately programmed okay
so if that happens if everything goes
well
then the penis will develop it'll have a
certain size
and then there's something which is very
key to
to my research which is something you
might know by the name of the taint
mm-hmm that taint or we call it
anogenital distance
yeah it's not a real it's not really a
technical term is it
but ain't no genital distances yes but
taint at solaris
listening to a phd right well i'm saying
that because i'm talking to a lot of
people
who might not know the area known as the
okay yes um known on the street as they
take
the streets and um or the gooch or the
grendel or
gooch i've never known that's the gooch
you know about the ghosts yeah actually
i just saw
someone the other day didn't know what a
taint was and they're like oh you mean
the gooch i
didn't i've never heard the gooch yeah i
thought the gooch was like a baseball
player
well it could be that also but isn't
there a guy named maybe he's named after
it
sorry and also abc have you heard abc
abc no i have not heard that
how's that one go ask ball connector oh
the ass ball connector
okay yeah okay for a woman
yes you can imagine yeah it's not called
an abc it's not called abc
okay sorry so here you got this distance
and
um it's been measured in animals for
like 100 years
and what they use it for was first to
just sex the animal so
the litter is born there's a lot of
little pups they want to separate the
males and the females because they're
going to do different things with them
and they just hold them up by the tail
and they look and the reason you can do
this is because in the mail
it's much longer it's 50 to 100 percent
longer
now this is stop and think about this
there's nothing else in the body that's
that different between
males and females in terms of size
organs yes but size no
you know our heights don't differ by 50
to 100 percent or weights nothing
nothing it's this is it this is the
the mark is that in all animals it's
almost all mammals
really the hyena's a little different we
could talk yeah though i know about
those you know over there
i have a whole bit about them yeah um
so you know they're mad the females are
masculine so they have a longer
agd right but most
for most mammals it's this way okay
including humans so here's this
little pup that's born and he's if he's
unexposed he'll have a good you know
standard
penal size and agd and he won't have any
malformations of his penis and so on you
know he'll be
normal but if his mother was exposed to
phthalates
everything can go south and what happens
is the penis is smaller
and the agd is smaller and the scrotum
is smaller
and the testes are maybe not descended
in other words it didn't finish the
process
it was arrested if you will so we say
that
that that pup is incompletely
masculinized
now the amount of phthalates that get
into the pup
system in you in vitro in in utero
is that the same is that possible to
achieve those levels in the modern world
with human beings
absolutely it is and i'm going to tell
you
what i did to show that i showed that
wow so when i heard the story
i was flying on a plane to japan to go
to a conference
i was with a friend who was a chemist
for the centers for disease control
and he said shauna you should study
phthalates
and i'm going why i'd never heard of
them what why phthalates
and he said well we have been measuring
them at the cdc
and they're in everybody they're in
pregnant women
and this group of scientists
in the national toxicology program has
shown
that they altered the development of the
male newborn
and they called that the phthalate
syndrome
that's what it's called that collection
of changes that come about after the
mother has phthalates is called the
phthalate syndrome
so i thought well does that happen in
humans
same question you asked right
so how do you how would you how would
you answer that question
then i'll tell you what i did how would
i well
you would hope that you're not running
experiments like you're running on
animals right um are you
measuring the blood of the people
that are having children that have
issues like with with uh
development developmental issues in the
way the children look when they're born
is that what you're doing it's really
close
so phthalates have the
property that they dissolve in water
they're water soluble
and so they go into the urine so for
this class of chemicals
if you want to know how much is in your
body my body we've got to measure the
urine
other chemicals um like flame returns we
would look in the blood
so it depends what what the chemical is
but but your right idea look inside
the body okay then rather than looking
at kids with
problems what i did was i just took a
whole population of pregnant women
and i got their urine measured their
phthalates
got their kids measured their kids
so then i had the problem of what to
measure in the kids because nobody had
made this translation from an animal
genital developmental system
to a human and so that was kind of a
challenge
you know figuring out how to do that but
we did that and we developed this
system for this exam for measuring all
these things that you measure
in a rat we measured it in our children
and then we showed and this was big news
when it came out that the mother salads
did alter the genitals of the boys
so that was the first evidence that was
2005.
and then we published some more in 2008
and then we
fortunately i got money to do it all
again nih doesn't like to pay for
replication it's very expensive these
things are five million dollars a study
by the way
well it seems like it's very important
though yeah so they gave it to me
they gave me money to do it again so the
second time i did it better because i
really knew what i was looking for
and i got urine actually in three points
in pregnancy
and i measure the kids exactly when
they're born
so everything was much more precise and
i found it again
so now there's no question i don't think
anyone questions that
at least this class of chemicals which
we know
lower testosterone alter
the development of these boys
and then i asked well what does that
have to do with sperm count because
actually for a long time we haven't
talked yet about sperm count but i've
been
studying tracing you know what's
happening with sperm count
i'll tell you the history of that in a
minute but so then i thought well is
this related to sperm count
well these are babies they don't have a
sperm count
but in rats it looked like
the agd was permanent so if you were
had a short just like if you have a
small hand you know your statures
certain set it at birth right so the agd
if you're born small and my friend earl
grey who was a toxicologist said aged
forever we don't know that for sure
about humans by the way
but um because we haven't had the 20
years yet but
um if you believe that then a sensible
thing to do
was to take a group of adult men who
could give you a sperm count
and measure their agd right
and then you could see whether those
with a shorter agd
had a lower sperm count and then you
would have one
pretty solid piece of evidence that
chemicals in the environment
lower sperm cap are you with me yes
ma'am
okay so i did that study too
so i got students in rochester new york
to volunteer for 75 bucks
to participate and they gave us a semen
sample and they gave us
opportunity to measure them also a
questionnaire
how does one measure kids taints do they
just bend over and you
bust out a ruler i happen to bring it
bring you something to show you yes i
noticed you had this
measuring device
jamie's volunteered to let you measure
his taint by the way so
um this is not for a baby
this is for this is for our rochester
young men study
um and it looks kind of
fierce um but we had the points
taken down yeah i used one of those to
measure uh
pool cue tips there you go all right so
you know all about it yeah
turn it on you want 13 millimeters
that's what i like but only for
so look um i also brought you a little
diagram
so you see where we measure okay but we
can't show this
i don't know how it shows so the
calipers are in
they're in millimeters or in inches or
both both you can
yeah yeah and and so oh boy you got a
diagram is there a chart online i could
look up like a
how about i just hold this up okay yeah
that works too yeah
all right
can we have a selfie with you and me in
that picture yes ma'am
okay all right so what i wanted to
so when i published this the uh the
headlines were
size matters but it's not what you think
right
right yeah and so i got all these people
asking me
what should it be what's good enough
what's big enough
so i did this translation from the
millimeters for you so
here it is the two inches is
at is the median okay okay
and in this population and
um here's the kicker if it was less than
two
men who had less than two inches were
seven times more likely
to have a sperm count in the subfertile
range
i can tell you what that is as men who
had an agd longer
than two inches wow
seven times it certainly
is related to sperm count and then
another study in california showed that
infertile men in an infertility clinic
versus men who had come
had borne a child had smaller
taint legs when did
this stuff start getting into our food
supply does that is that
been estimated so
the growth of these chemicals
um tracks with the growth of
the petrochemical industry because
they're made from petrochemical
byproducts okay so if you look at a
curve
of the growth it starts around the 50
1950 okay
so back in 1950 you have
people loving science jumping on the
science bandwagon
there's this better living through
chemistry that everyone's talking about
and everybody is just wanting everything
made of plastic
you know it's the new it's the new craze
it's the new you know
and and it just took off it went faster
than a straight line
you know exponentially up and so
somewhere in there
it started having an effect but where
we're not sure but i did look at the
decline in sperm count over time so we
could look at that
as an indication that this is not the
only thing that's affecting sperm count
by the way this these phthalates but
that's one where i feel i can say this
with confidence because i
measured those babies and i you know i
did it
i did the science and i did it again and
i you know
and other people have done it and and so
it's
it's i believe it's solid and
um that's just one example of the many
chemicals
that can affect our hormone system catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience